all right let's get to the main story so
you're asking if there was some Andrew
Tate updates there has been a lot
actually basically he was he was
arrested and detained for 30 days they
keep trying to appeal it and the judge
is like no you're staying they now have
the option to extend it to like
150 days or something of Kipping him
yeah wow that's serious him and his
brother and his collaborators wow
and um the claims is that the women
claim they're being forced
by the British Brothers uh
the current arrests they've seized all
of his cars they're going to sell all of
his supercars to pay for the
investigation and to go to the victims
how bad wow dude that's the best they've
impounded all of his cars and they're
selling four million dollars worth of
assets It All Started from the Tweet
about the cars to to Greta very true
that's amazing it's so good it's the
greatest story it's always under
investigation for a long time before
that but the timing was the diet this
this whole story is like amazing
yesterday we found out there's been like
an ongoing high level okay deep
investigation for nine months including
like the Romanian FBI anti-terror unit
serious [ __ ] I think what happened with
him is that he was paying off like
people and local police but he
he flew too close to the Sun as they say
and attracted
fish that were way too big for him to
handle
and so the FBI is basically of Romania
set up this really elaborate
investigation including wiretapping they
have wiretaps of him saying crazy [ __ ]
yeah so he is a guy mega mega [ __ ] and
people keep saying is he gonna go I
think he's gonna go to jail for like 15
years like he is done cooked cooked um
let's see they They seized his cars his
watches
ton of just straight cash she had they
just took all of his [ __ ]
damn it is the Matrix bro the make just
got your got him
so we're gonna do some justice in 2023 I
think he's going down hard they say the
authorities in Romania said the police
served search warrants at five homes I
took four suspects into custody
including the two brothers
this is crazy this girl recorded this
conversation of him and she went to the
UK police and said hey this guy's our
worded me you need to do something
here's the evidence of him and they
didn't do [ __ ] Hassan actually when I
was on his stream told me something
really interesting that the UK has like
a a really systematic
problem with Prosecuting sexual crimes
like they were like not believing women
not following up and statistically the
amount of cases that they were trying
first the amount reported was like
insanely insanely insanely low wow so
it's a recent development now where the
UK is trying to get that number up and
get more because it was like a big
Scandal so this happened during that big
scandal
where they were not like going after
sexual predators and the listen I mean
this is a trigger warning uh but here's
the audio that she recorded
and sent to the police Vice news got
this from the girl
and um
and published it so again trigger
warning it's a minute long
it's an audio message
it's just audio yeah oh it's an audio
messages he sent her so here it is here
it is audio notes am I a bad person
because the more you didn't like it the
more I enjoyed it I [ __ ] yeah
yes
well I'll answer it yeah question for
you yes all right I'm not gonna pause I
just like am I a bad person because the
more you didn't like it the more I
enjoyed it I [ __ ] loved how much you
hated it turned me on oh my God why am I
like that
why I am one of the most dangerous men
on this planet sometimes you forget
exactly how lucky you were to get [ __ ]
by me would you rather me pin you down
and make you do things you didn't like
or would you rather [ __ ]
you didn't like the I was thinking I can
do whatever I want to
that's what it is I'm the smartest
person on this [ __ ] planet Are you
seriously so offended I strangled you a
little bit you didn't [ __ ] pass out
chill the [ __ ] out Jesus Christ I
thought you were cool what's wrong with
you wow yeah so this is a voice note
that was in possession of the UK police
they were doing an investigation we
found out one of the things we found out
is he was kicked off Big Brother
mysteriously I don't know if you heard
this but the news so Vice has been doing
really good reporting on this they found
out the reason he was removed from Big
Brother is because he was under
investigation by the police for our word
and when they found that out they said
you got to get off the show Jesus so
this guy has a long-standing history of
uh
of doing this kind of stuff and so there
there's one that that was one thing that
broke a vice report said that the
WhatsApp messages and voice notes
uh from this girl says he R worded her
in 2013.
she said the police told her they
believe her account but authorities
declined to prosecute a recreate so this
is the message he sent as Vice reported
and uh again trigger warning guys just
give me like a minute here but these
again just to show you he says I love
art word in you and watching you let me
while still debating if it's a good idea
or not monsters are monsters when you're
under my control I do whatever I please
you were my
poor when I had my hands on you
wow
okay
um you know if I I know that Tate's fans
are gonna be like she's lying and she
liked it like that video of him like oh
yeah she like there's it was consensual
it's like if she has these messages and
she says she was R worded she was like
there's no [ __ ] room for debate I
always ask for proof and usually these
are the kind of things you can't prove
unless you're in the room but this is as
close as you can having evidence the
smartest man in the world loves just
loves putting his own crimes in writing
yeah like that is his favorite thing to
do is let me record myself detailing all
of my well wait if you think that's
smart wait to see the next [ __ ] this
next stuff isn't trigger warning but
yeah okay but I just want to say his
fans think those voice notes aren't real
by the way they're arguing that that's
not him in those voice members oh okay I
think the reason why because when I
listen to it I had that thought too yeah
it's because they're tight little voice
notes and they edit them together so it
sounds a little artificial but it's
definitely him guys come on don't be
[ __ ] morons
so he so he was caught on wire tape
wiretap admitting to money laundering
and other crimes was transcribed by a
Romanian news website
called digi24 it reads Tate you're not
stupid and you can probably guess how
much
I make so much how I make so much money
I have to hide what I'm really doing the
victim said webcam Tate responded for a
long time I did this with the team of
girls working on video chat the company
was fake but this is how I laundered my
dirty money some of the girls who worked
for me I used them to do other things to
move money or illegal things documents
Etc I will never do that with you
you're different baby yeah
and then I had never seen these videos
and I don't know where
wait I don't want I don't want this
lawyer talking about I want the video I
I couldn't find the original videos so
so it's just him watching it yeah and he
gives a little bit of commentary his
commentary is good though so I mean it's
not it's not so this video that came out
I don't know where it came from but it's
so [ __ ] crazy
this must have been like part of water
University from what I understood it was
the predecessor to Hustler University
but it was a similar scam that he was
running where he was educating people
about basically how to run a him
organization dude listen to this this is
the advice he's giving to men and and
y'all really wondering if he's just
listen it's mind-blowing tax is also
another important element for
controlling your woman
they're not going to pay anybody tax
because you're getting paid in Bitcoin
so you don't need to pay tax to anybody
that's not lie that's not real that's
not real oh my God our God that's for
sure not right is that what guys are
saying that he's like helped them so
much and so inspired Rush when that
Stacks first he's like yo I don't think
yo Andrew says I don't pay taxes if I
get paid in Bitcoin because like you
hear so much of a guy saying I look up
to him he helped me so much
50 50. that's not even the craziest part
so that you're paying the tax
because girls are lazy you know this is
stupid and girls don't understand how
taxes work so the girl he says as he's
16. it sounds like you're not
understanding oh my God
the nuances of not paying taxes yeah oh
hello Bitcoin
although there wasn't there was a time
like when Bitcoin wasn't audited but it
wasn't that long I think I don't know
the thing is Bitcoin it's hard to track
and so it's it's much easier when you
take it out into your bank then they
[ __ ] exactly and that's it's not that
it's legal or that you don't get taxed
on bitcoin it's that you can
theoretically hide it a lot easier than
you could but you can't use it without
being taxed exactly
not supposed to do that yes exactly you
can and easier yes you know well there's
laws about it now so
I guess now he's just having a big joke
out of it I mean I I mean at least in
America I'm not sure what the legal
system is in Romania or UK or wherever
the [ __ ] he was when he was doing this
but again again
this it gets way crazier yeah we've made
this much money but I'm gonna pay the
tax to make sure we don't get in trouble
she'll sit there go okay okay
now that allows you to do two things one
is another control element see how that
control is is a recurring theme over and
over and over again I work with him my
tax is not a problem if I do it alone I
have to deal with taxes taxes are
complicated it's a control element and
he doesn't have respect for these women
at all because he thinks they're stupid
it allows you to pay her a smaller
percentage
so I used to pay my girls 13 percent
so for every ten thousand dollars they
made I give them three and I keep seven
they thought they were on fifty percent
and I said that the disparity was
because of taxes so you're on fifty
percent we had to pay the tax first and
then it's 50 50. this man is literally
reporting himself he's doing fraud yeah
to like tax fraud and normal fraud like
two layers of fraud Happening Here
scamming people and that's your
Technique guys for self-improvement just
watch this okay like guys this man
filmed himself doing this and he's just
smart what the [ __ ] the smartest man
alive is helping young man Ethan he's so
inspiring stuff bro
is this mind-bending [ __ ] and what I
can't get over is like how this video is
so underground apparently yeah I don't
know how it Unearthed all of a sudden
but man wow I'm sure the police got it
oh yeah let's think of how to dig
ourselves
it's on video
because I'm the one typing I'm
bringing you're working in I'm the one
paying the bills the electricity I'm the
one who's uh and the electricity and
everything
what was that you know what there was
someone
he just mentioned something and this was
a detail that because I watched most of
this video and he talks about how he
doesn't do this anymore but when he was
starting his business he was having
these cam girls perform or whatever and
then they would chat with guys as well
and he kept saying I don't actually have
the girls do that I was doing that it
did yes and so this dude is doing phone
sex with you no yeah well not phone
check but like chatting he was cyber
sexing with dudes at like until he got
successful enough that he says then then
he hired people and they took over doing
that but he very casually was just like
talking about how he was the Super
alphabet hey baby what are you wearing
yeah took a little bit I just thought
that was that's why this conversations
would add in and then I started going so
well well so authentic right he's got a
lot of experience yeah Aidan's just
another paying client exactly
this shit's crazy dude so this is nuts
right I mean this is really something
this is mind-blowing I already knew you
know the guy was a piece of [ __ ] like
scum to the scummiest level but this is
just when you're talking about like
crying so in your face he's just saying
it all awesome dude that's awesome it's
so good you're working in I'm the one
paying the bills the electricity I'm the
one who's uh and the electricity and
every other maintenance cost of this
property I'm the one who bought the
equipment I'm the one who knows what
he's doing I'm the one with the
knowledge
shut the [ __ ] up go online
and they should be pretty happy with
that they respect you as a person
overall so really you're paying 30 you
tell them you're paying 50. the
difference is in the tax
that's where the disparity lies taxes
disparities they don't believe you or
they want to get fresh or whatever print
out some tax forms I see this all the
time I used to print out some randomly
it's crazy it's like just lie lie lie
lie lie whatever it is that you need
just lie about it thank you he's just
real psychopath this is like really
Psychopathic Behavior yeah what's crazy
is he's gonna give them 15 only because
he or is it 30 30 but then on that 30
they're still gonna owe taxes of course
no transparency the number is whatever
it wants it to be yeah because there's
nothing expenses
now he goes oh yeah and I faked
documents too yeah fake tax forms you
fake it there's another big crime right
there smartest man in the world right
here wow knowledge
shut the [ __ ] up go online
and they should be pretty happy with
that if they respect you as a person
overall so really you're paying 30 you
tell them you're paying 50 difference is
in the tax
that's where the disparity lies taxes
come on if you if they don't need you
they want to get fresh or whatever print
out some tax forms I see this all the
time dude you're filming this and
putting it online
fake
fraudulently fake tax forms are you you
do it all the time all the time
regularly
holy [ __ ] what a idiot and the thing is
is that this on its own probably
almost definitely wouldn't have been
enough to get them because
um you could just say he was
bullshitting or whatever right you know
what I mean like him saying this alone
isn't enough to charge him but
they with all of the documentation that
they have got on him and everything
um and wiretapping and hearing him talk
about this in private then something
like this becomes corroborating evidence
for all of the things and all of a
sudden it's like well no you're not
lying you're detailing your criminal
Empire right well also these are easy to
follow up especially if they have his
his victims they can they can trace all
this [ __ ] back right check the taxes and
all this [ __ ] and I think he's going to
get nailed for this one for wire fraud
for money laundering right it's not even
just human trafficking at this point
wow somebody said [ __ ] thought
he was in a deposition yeah
deposition Academy
holy [ __ ] dude it's like you didn't make
the plea deal yet bro
you don't have to be that honest
yeah somebody said if Trisha thought
five percent was bad
20 would you imagine if Andrew Tate was
their partner all right
tax forms so yeah sign here and sign
this what is it it's for the tax you
want to pay the tax or not
okay and they just sign away I don't
want the [ __ ] sign in let's throw
them away afterwards but they don't
think something's happening something
real is happening nothing's happening
it's like medium or HP nothing's
happening
this
it's crazy it's so dumb
nothing's happening but I'm getting rich
[ __ ] anyway so tax is another important
element to keep control of the girl you
have to talk to girls you could not do a
business relationship with a female I'll
tell you why
women have sex
with somebody if they're not [ __ ] you
they're talking to somebody else now a
woman is always going to be the most
loyal to the guy she's talking as
opposed to anyone else for any other
reason
if you're the girl work for you you say
look
I'm gonna have a brain damage
here's the [ __ ] I've had dudes I've
done loads of guys who's like trying to
do a contract with a girl
anyway whatever he goes on it's all bad
but then now he goes on to detail how
exactly how he human trafficks people he
actually put this [ __ ] on camera so we
got the fraud but now here's here's the
really good stuff uh quote unquote good
stuff
I want to do that so okay I know you
don't want to do that but listen come
let's have a meeting let's just talk
about it if you don't want to do it
don't do it fine but let me explain it
to you properly in fact I'll bring one
of the girls who works for me
you your Bolton [ __ ] the new girl you
go out for [ __ ] a nice dinner your
Bolton [ __ ] is the one who does the
selling you don't do the selling the
girl has to hear from a girl and this is
where your Bolton [ __ ] has to be
trained and so I said it's so important
to have a good first girl remember Glenn
Maxwell that was the girl that recruited
for Jeffrey Epstein almost identical to
what he's talking about here that's what
I keep saying he's just he's he's
Jeffrey Epstein Junior yeah yeah
foreign
he thinks he invented pimping by the way
context you have the way he structured
his business
one of the ways that he's lured the
girls by having another girl there
identical to what um Epstein was doing
now
and this is the this is a danger when
you have so much stuff that's out there
that's reckless right let's see what he
has to say about the the uh Romanian
court system
and their jails
they're corruption free that we all know
let's put me in jail I'm gonna walk in
there with a pile of money like this I'm
gonna walk in there that worked for you
like this can you walk in there with a
pile of money
actually funny he went in there and they
went and took this money and kept his
ass there
right didn't work out quite the way you
envisioned
he's now in a jail
remain this video is actually is now by
the way hats off to
CLR Bruce Rivers this is actually he has
all the receipts yeah this man came so
fast
I wasn't familiar with him
how do you do this I wasn't familiar
with him until I saw this video I just
stumbled upon this it was just on my
front page of YouTube oh he's a big
Channel actually 700 yeah I was about to
say a lot of people in our chat seem
familiar with him and say they're
they're good to his so I I like he
watches these Rock videos it's so fun
wait he raps no he he reviews rap videos
with like guns in it oh say
incriminating their crime yeah that's
awesome
I'm going to be subject to the courts in
Romanian he just on this video I'm sure
the prosecutors have this because I have
if I have it they have it yeah flouting
taunting
showing complete and utter disregard for
the remaining court system which he's
now going to be facing now if you recall
the statement from his own lawyer said
Mr Tate has nothing but the utmost
respect
for the court system well that's not
what it says here he calls it so
effectively what webcam company doing it
is doing is is mining Bitcoin but in
fact it's sort of mining Bitcoin the
traditional way with huge electricity
expenses and massively expensive
equipment with space and cooling all
Apple [ __ ] you mind Bitcoin with some
[ __ ] and titties you mind Bitcoins
that's what he just said take that out
of context
dude he's awesome go off Bruce Bruce is
King dude
bash
entertained although I'm not a fan and I
don't care to even pretend that I'm a
fake but it's an interesting case it's
interesting case because it has
International intrigue
but you also have from his own words
the control aspect how important it is
to control these women I I think the
government with this video with just
this one video alone that's an excellent
Foundation wow for the sex trafficking
Church whoa but more than that they also
have
otter probably a tax beef I think in
Levy against him once they start diving
into his books oh he's analyzing this I
really don't want you to think I'm
taking anything out of context because
I'm not but let's see in his own words
how he's recruited Lord or
retain these girls
then you start you see he's cooked he's
like [ __ ] done done done yeah when
this first
the news first happened in my mind it
was just like ah people like him nothing
bad ever happens to them or whatever but
right when you really break it down and
you factor in the whole fact that he so
publicly was like yeah I'm just gonna
pay off the police uh they're corrupt it
doesn't matter yeah
um
he really [ __ ] cornered himself with
that because I mean even if they were
corrupt and that was an option before
now it's not because he specifically
said that and so they're not gonna
they're gonna intentionally double down
on going after him to prove that you
know they're on the up and ups there's
only one man that who could get him out
of this
do you have a Authority in Romania
credentials
wild [ __ ] yo and again this whole video
is actually worth a good watch yeah
because
yeah he's [ __ ] so I mean that's good
that's great right there yeah I think
that's that's awesome I mean I think
it's I'm just really happy about this to
be honest oh yeah and his they his peeps
they go oh so you're happy that there's
victims I was hoping he was innocent
which means there's no victims
no a lot that's like a popular argument
they go oh so let me get this straight
you're hoping that there's victims by
saying that you want them to go to jail
oh my God swear to God this people been
saying wow I swear you'll see it out
there you'll see it